good morning good afternoon good evening
depending on where you're joining us
from welcome to simply learn my name is
richard and after this intro i'll be
mostly in the background helping shakar
so that everything goes smoothly if
you're not familiar with shakar he is an
expert in the
sales force
for those who are not familiar with this
form of webinar i want to introduce you
to the dashboard or control board if
everyone could locate your dashboard
control board and then locate the
question module on there
go ahead and message hello in the
question module just say hello to shakar
and let him know you're excited to be
here this lets us know you are hearing
us okay
there we go and it's usually up on the
right hand side if you if it's closed
automatically you can click that red
arrow to reopen it
all right uh let's see i'm not seeing
anybody in here is everybody able to
hear me okay if you can just type in
something in the question module let us
know that you're here
yes uh yes richard we are able to hear
you
okay excellent
glad to have you guys aboard the
question module is your best friend
uh as you're going through you can
present questions in here which we'll
answer at the end in a qa session
if you have a specific question on your
career or real world world journey post
it here and we'll look into that and
answer as many questions we can
if you hear something awesome brilliant
interesting and you want to share it in
your social channels whatever your
social channels are facebook linkedin
tweet
you can use the hashtag snl webinars and
let people so let people know that you
were here and what's going on
i know the other day i was using our
local network meetup a great place to
follow up on a meeting so i heard some
interesting stuff here and just put it
right on there and a lot of people are
able to go in there and take a look at
that and reference it to the sl webinars
you didn't come here to listen to me i
am proud to introduce shakar who will be
your host go ahead and sit back relax
have a cup of coffee tea or if it's in
the evening where you're at maybe a
glass of wine and enjoy it's an honor
for me to hand this over to shakkar
thank you and happy learning shakar
yes
uh thanks a lot uh
for the introduction
welcome friends so
so
welcome to this amazing
world of salesforce
to get some idea information about this
tool and to understand why this tool is
making fantastic
difference in the current market
my name is shekhar and i'm going to
give you some very interesting
information which can completely
transform your career and give you one
clarity like how you can make your
career
safe
best as well as secure
let me start first with the agenda if
you can see on the screen it shows that
our focus today is to understand why one
should consider
a career in salesforce what is so
special in this amazing tool
that is making so much difference in the
market and large number of people are
changing their career and coming to
sales force or starting their career
with salesforce
let's first discuss the agenda take away
or what you are going to get in this
today's session
first of all
you can see here i have
i have the agenda on the screen so first
we'll understand what will be today's
plan what we are going to understand
so first of all please note that we will
focus
understand about sales force if anyone
is there in this session who is
completely unaware about this sales
force then it's a good chance for you
to understand
why there is so much buzz
about this tool in the market why it is
so much important
then we are going to see what is the
current market situation
before deciding any technology as a
career option
we should also understand what is the
market situation
once we do a careful analysis about the
market the future as well as the
possibilities then only it is wise
to jump into that technology or proceed
for that
you can say branch of the market
next we are going to see sales for job
trends
the most important thing
the ultimate goal of us is having a best
and
good quality job which will be
giving us a way or path for bright
career
then we are going to see if we are
looking for salesforce as a career
option then what are the possible
options
then we will see
finally how salesforce is safe career
option in this roller coaster market you
might be knowing uh all these ups and
downs in the market something regularly
coming as a
as a concept like for example uh let's
say recession or let's say some kind of
tragedy or let's say some kind of
political issue some kind of global
issue and ultimately
regularly we can see that there is
insecurity about the job
but how sales force career option can
give you a very safe career path that
also we are going to discuss here and
finally a very good chance for you all
to ask all
questions about your career your plans
where i can guide you well
and you can get a clear idea what you
are going to what you need to do here
onwards let's start the agenda it will
be definitely interesting session it's
my guarantee to you
first point that is about salesforce
now
first of all we are going to understand
why there is so much buzz
noise about salesforce why these big
companies are coming to salesforce and
exactly what is salesforce
first of all please note salesforce
started the career or journey or this
entry in the market as a crm tool
it's actually a crm tool
which started the journey in
march 1999
means customer relationship management
so it all started in march 1999
where
people were
started understanding the importance of
crm tool and one person
mark binioff
who left a high salary job
decided to start a company
based on crm technology
with
the connection cloud
and this way he started a company sales
force in march 1999
and this is the way how the journey
started
please note it's very interesting to see
that the focus was only as a crm tool
customer relationship management tool to
only focus on
uh guys uh if anyone is having mic open
then please mute the mic so we can have
a silent session
so requesting everyone if anyone is my
having mic open please mute that
fine thank you
so it will be very interesting for you
to understand even though the journey
started as a crm tool but ultimately the
things are now
absolutely amazing for example
the company which started focusing on
a
you can say search engine
in a small garage
is now a billionaire company that is
google
their initial plan
was just to provide a tool for searching
something quickly on internet but now
google is everywhere you can see there
is a mobile from google operating system
browser
variable device glass automated car
search let's say social media that is
google plus there are plenty of things
which google is right now working in
same with salesforce
salesforce started as a crm tool but now
it's
almost everywhere in the market so which
domains
right now in which domains right now
salesforce is giving the performance
healthcare
marketing shipping finance sales service
education now salesforce is almost
everywhere
and that is the reason
if you compare
with other companies
you will realize that salesforce is
literally making the magical
progress in the market
let me tell you one important and very
useful slide which will definitely
impress you and tell you that how
salesforce is one of the best tool
as compared to the other competitors in
the market and this way you will
understand
that how salesforce has become a market
changer so now i'm going to show you one
slide which was
recently released by one of the very
famous agency called as gartner so let
me now show you the slide
okay so i just got one message in the
chat box i was replying and
please see this
if you understand this slide very well
it will be very easy to understand that
where the market is going and you can
take good decision for your career see
this is the recent survey released by
one of the very very famous agency in
the market gartner you might have heard
this name plenty of time
you can see here gartner recently
released one survey which shows how fan
in a fantastic manner salesforce is
making the change in the market for
example
let's talk about this
sap
the major
or the most strong competitor to
salesforce
they started well
but now it's regularly coming down and
down sap is losing the market in crm
domain
let's talk about oracle
the owner of java
they started also somewhere around at
12.6
continuously it's coming down and down
and down and it's now at 9.1 again very
bad performance
let's talk about microsoft crm the owner
of this company world's richest person
started with 5.7
very bad number
and non-stop there performing very very
much average scoring and right now it's
somewhere around 6.2 which shows again
there is no much competition or no much
such threat for salesforce
with this all other
companies
and just look at this
sales force started with 10.6
and continuously non-stop is going up
and up and up and you can see right now
it's somewhere around 18.4 and can you
see can you see this this is called as a
dream graph this is nothing but a dream
of each and every company each and every
ceo or each and every investor to have
such kind of graph for the company never
going down always going up
and please note guys
when you compare the global market this
difference
6.3 percentage is really a very big
number 6.3 is not a small number when
you compare the global market and this
shows where the world is moving
sales force
and this gap is going to be regularly up
and up and this way these companies will
lose the market
all the existing companies will start
coming to salesforce and this way we
will have so much opportunity so many
jobs in the market at the global level
i have seen plenty of companies in the
market they are leaving now sap oracle
projects and they are coming to
salesforce because of some fantastic
features which salesforce is providing
to them
and this is the reason why the market is
simply focusing on salesforce whenever
we are talking about these crm tools and
other segments
let's move to next point
now
after understanding the comparison with
other companies
let me tell you
is it really market so much
crazy for salesforce what are the big
brands
or some big companies
which is completely relying on
salesforce as their internal important
tool
some big names are like coca-cola
google
ebay
ge
phillips
there are plenty of big brands in the
market they are completely depending on
sales force and you can understand if
these companies are completely depending
on sales force then as compared to their
size their strength
they have employees in thousands
definitely you can understand
how much option we can get in such big
companies to get a job on salesforce
i have seen my plenty of students
working in some big companies like
google coca-cola and all because there
is huge demand right now in this market
for these big companies on sales force
so this is something about salesforce
for all those people who are completely
unaware about this amazing tool
after understanding from after
understanding sales force and the
background and all
the journey it
made till this point
let's see the market situation of sales
force that is how is the market and what
kind of opportunities you have
first of all let me tell you one
important thing
in the market
salesforce is one of the hot technology
and
you can very much
unders you can understand very much
clearly that whenever any technology is
hot
in this case there will be thousands of
candidate will be in demand
i have seen some big companies recently
they are having the recruitment
requirement of thousands of people
thousands of candidates
every year because their all old clients
are coming to salesforce for example let
me tell you one latest example you might
have heard the name of the company
accenture it's a very big company
working on salesforce they recently had
a plan to hire almost 1 000 people
this shows that how big the demand is
for salesforce people in the market and
this is because the market is very hot
another thing
whenever
the companies are going to hire some
people
for any particular technology or for any
particular domain please note there is
one more important thing that those
people are having some kind of
connection or touch with salesforce they
are getting high priority in terms of
resistance filtering process
because
those people who have who are having
slight bit of knowledge or idea about
salesforce companies are hiring them on
priority because they know that
ultimately these people will help us and
will get the benefit of these people
when we will completely roll out
our current process on salesforce
another important advantage
third
what clients are demanding in the market
please note if you are trying to have a
job in a service based company
please note clients are having huge
demand they are making huge demand for
those people who are salesforce
certified
and this is one more advantage for us if
we are certified on salesforce these
service based companies will need us
and they will hire us without much
struggle these are all advantage we will
have right now because the market is
very hot for salesforce and we are going
to get this advantage automatically
without making much efforts
and finally when those people who are
certified in salesforce
their salary estimation will be also
depending on that for example
if you are a salesforce certified person
then you can expect some fantastic
numbers in terms of your salary about
which i will be speaking in a very short
time and then you will realize that what
power your resume will get
just by having a label of salesforce
certified if you just have this label on
your resume you can understand how much
amazing numbers you can expect in terms
of salary which i will tell you very
shortly just stay tuned this will be
very important for you to understand
what you should do
in your career in terms of next change
now
we will see how we can plan a career in
salesforce that is
what kind of jobs we can have in
salesforce what are the areas where we
can work and depending on your
background
depending on your skill set we can
decide here that how the market is
moving and then you can take a decision
where i fit best
please note
just by
estimating that sales force is very hot
in the market and sales force is very
good
it's not wise decision to directly jump
on to that
first we should understand that what are
the possible ways possible areas where i
can make my career in salesforce and
that for that reason
the next slide which i'm going to show
you it's absolutely important please pay
attention all those people who are
coming from different backgrounds or if
they if you are thinking that what will
be the suitable position for me in
salesforce career
you can get plenty of knowledge in the
next slide so please pay attention
let's talk about salesforce job trend
where is the market going what kind of
options i have in the salesforce job
trend
please note
that in salesforce domain there are
plenty of job opportunities and
the trend is going towards these roles
like admin
developer
business analyst
architect consultant and so many other
options are there but here i am going to
focus on those things which are
absolutely important in the market they
are having so much demand so that you
can get the knowledge of that and decide
that which will be suitable option for
you also compare your background in
which background you're coming from and
compare with the explanation that i'm
going to give you right now and this way
you can realize
where you suit best okay so let's start
understanding one by one about this job
trend
first of all the ad main job
segment in the market
please note
all those people
who are completely unaware or not having
idea about
programming
development or coding for them this
first option admin is the best way
because if you are having no idea about
programming then still
you can create fantastic applications
end-to-end project in salesforce without
writing a single line of code and this
is really fantastic
because
creating an entire project without
writing single line of code is the
special thing of salesforce because of
which
many people having no idea about
programming they are also making good
career in salesforce so please note even
though you don't have any programming
background nothing to worry you have so
many things available in salesforce you
can do
completely without any programming
knowledge
that is admin
next
for those people who are having or who
knows
some kind of programming let's say java
dot net or etc then they can go for a
second
option which is again a very hot job
trend in the market developer or sales
force developer
please note that all those activities
all those functionalities which is not
possible by admin people
and there should be compulsory some
programming to be done to achieve the
result
we have second option called as
developer
so if you have any background of
programming please don't miss this
opportunity
to go for a developer career option of
salesforce because just
making a small understanding
small hard work
you can completely
be comfortable on developer branch of
salesforce because
the way
java.net and other programming languages
follow the principle of object oriented
concept
same way salesforce also following the
same so it will not be difficult for you
to convert from other programming
language to salesforce programming
language please note in salesforce the
programming language that we use is
called as apex
and also one interesting point for you
this apex programming language is the
world's first programming language that
can work on cloud
that is before this apex language there
was no such language in the market which
can run on internet and this is the gift
of sales force given to it world because
before apex
we never could write a program on
internet and this was this is really
something special we don't need to
install anything on our laptop
no database no setup no configuration
open the internet directly start doing
programming this is a gift of salesforce
next
and the platform on which we do the
programming in salesforce is called
as force.com so nothing to download
nothing to install this platform is
ready for you simply start programming
very very simple
if you go for other technologies you
have to install something like visual
studio something like eclipse something
like netbeans and finally start working
here
nothing to install directly start
working a plus point of sales force
third option you can see here
third option up is nothing but the
business analyst
now please note here in the business
analyst role i think some questions are
coming in the chat box so guys i will
appreciate if you ask more and more
question but we will take all these
questions at the end so that we will
have a continuous learning process so i
will request keep asking the question
but we will open the question box at the
end once we will finish all these things
just let me take one single question
right now which was there is nothing but
about the apex yes apex is a programming
language of sales force yes it's an
object-oriented programming language of
salesforce i hope you are clear okay
now we will talk talk about all these
questions at the end guys okay so please
have a patience and i will exp i will
give the answer of each and every
question in the last slide okay so let's
continue
third option is business analyst
now what is the meaning of that see
whenever your customer
will give you
the requirement
please note in real time projects the
process is
between you
and between the customer
there will be one important entity who
can understand both parties both
branches
and that will be called as a business
analyst because this person knows you
very well your limitations your
capabilities and this person knows very
well how to handle customer to realize
customers problem and also
understand how we can satisfy our
customer
so those people who are very well aware
about project management
dealing with customer understand the
functional side
and also they know the capability about
the developers or capabilities of any
developer they can be business analyst
another very fantastic very much
fantastic
uh segment in the market to have a
career in
please note plenty of people who are
well aware of admin capabilities
and they just understand what is the
meaning of developer but they never
but they have not done any kind of
programming in their career for them
this area is very much suitable because
they can understand the power of admin
power of developer and convince the
customer
convince the customer and let them know
that how the things are moving okay now
let me tell you
some important point just give one
second
now the next point guys is architect
this is the most important percent in
any salesforce project
absolutely fantastic salary
and also so much importance in any
salesforce project why because this
person should know this
this
this as well as this because he will be
completely the guide of your team and he
will be telling you what should be your
approach and how you should be working
and how you should be implementing the
project in a very short time
if you target this as your career option
then nothing better than this because
these people are absolutely in high
demand
absolutely high salary and they are most
precious in the market because the
entire project will be depending on
these people so if you can target
something like this nothing better than
this
finally a consultant again this person
will be not
this person will be not working exactly
as a admin or developer but he will be
having the combination of both a
consultant is that person who knows the
business very well
who knows the functionality very well
and that person will focus on various
segments
in the current market of sales force
this is also a very good trend if you
are planning to have a career on because
there are also some good jobs available
in the market as a consultant where you
will not be exactly admin
exactly developer but it will be a kind
of combination to perform various
activities in your project
these are top market trends in the
market
you can target anything definitely you
will have a very good career here
onwards
after understanding salesforce job trend
we should also understand the most
important thing
for everyone that is the
career option in terms of salary
what kind of roles we have
and what their salaries will be this
will be
definitely an eye opener for you because
the numbers that i'm going to tell you
the salaries we are going to discuss
right now
it will tell you that what is
y sales force is called as the best
career option in the current time
let me show you the career options in
salesforce in terms of the designation
and in terms of their average salaries
and these are the numbers
after taking the survey
of
almost 150
candidates
and taking the average salaries
here are the useful numbers for you to
decide your career option
please note all these
options
in salesforce
are related to those all branches which
i told you in the previous slide
technical architect the most important
person as i just said in the team he
will be leading the entire team and he
will be giving solutions he will be
telling you he will be guiding you and
also taking care of each and every
problem in terms of dead block
the average salary of technical
architect
is
135 000 dollars
next person who is again as i said right
now there is a good demand of those
people in the market consultants
who not only understand the business
well but also they understand the
capabilities of technical branch as well
the average salary for them is 120 000
next
the project managers
here anyone in this session
who is already working as a project
manager please note you all have a very
good chance to convert your career into
salesforce project management
please note here you will not have much
efforts
to convert your career option because
the way you control your project
the way you manage your project in this
current technology right now whatever
technology you are working in it's very
simple for you to understand salesforce
architecture
and with very less efforts or maybe a
practice of one or two weeks you can
completely understand how salesforce
works and this knowledge you can use for
managing a team
again a very good career option who are
at the managerial level
the average salary
98 000
next
salesforce business analyst if you
remember
just before sometime i said you this
entity will be a mediator between
customer
and you people like you and me who will
be working as a developer or admin they
know how to keep happy both the parties
their average salary
95 000 dollars
next
salesforce developers those people who
knows
programming very well
and their average salary is 90 000
and finally salesforce administrator
please note that administrator they will
be having some kind of limitations
because
they cannot perform each and everything
in the project definitely they can
perform an entire project without
programming but sometimes there are some
situations where they will face some
kind of limitations and that is the
reason as compared to developers
the administrators they have 70k salary
but
this shows you where you can go for and
how you can plan your career option
because the starting step should be
administer and one by one you can reach
this
ultimate level of architect which as i
said is in high demand or
much you can say the most
valuable entity in any sales force
project
so these are some good career options
you can compare from which background
you are coming and accordingly you can
decide your career option as well
and now we are coming to the
most important slide
that is the next slide
in this roller coaster market
when
every now and then
something new is coming
some old technologies are vanishing
many people losing job because
some xyz technology losing their market
many people finding difficult to get the
jobs because of the concepts like
recession and all
how we can consider
sales force as a safe career option or
if we migrate towards sales force as our
career option
then how it can ensure us
a safe path
it's a very important point for you all
guys and as well as me
because ultimately
it will be it is a matter of our career
of our future
let's discuss about the next slide how
salesforce is
safer
option in this roller coaster market
see
first of all
in the market there are plenty of
opportunities so many technologies
every year you will see some kind of
technology or some technology will be
coming which will rule the market for
few months or few years
and again after that
again after that what will happen it
will lose the market and finally
after losing the market it will be
having
uh it will be having a nightmare
situation for all those people who are
already working on the technology or
they started making career in that
so if you compare that situation
these problems you will not face in
salesforce how let me tell you
point number one
the job safety in salesforce is
absolutely fantastic
because in salesforce
you will not have a single branch or
single segment to work
salesforce is in healthcare
infrastructure
management
sales
service
support
finance
education
so you can now realize that actually
salesforce is not depending on this kind
of global scenarios like recessions and
all here salesforce is depending on
multiple branches of business
so here you have wide options
so many so many uh you can say
powerful segments available for you
where you can make the career
what about competition now we have just
seen the slide which shown
that as compared to the other companies
like sap
oracle
microsoft salesforce is having huge
growth
and this shows that
even if tomorrow
the market slightly changes
there is no one as a strong competition
to sales force because of which we may
have some kind of risk in our job
another big important point because we
know very well that even a small
fluctuation happens
in the market
some other technology will rise as a big
competitor but here whatever we have
seen in that graph it makes us very
clear that there is no such strong
competition to sales force
next
wide scope
please note salesforce is not only as a
crm tool in the market
you can use salesforce as a mobile
device with various apps
you can run your sales business
you can you can
build your business in terms of a
service industry
you can run a call center
you can run your hospital
you can even use some fantastic tools
like an android device you can say any
android app ios app as well as various
websites also possible in salesforce it
means there is not a single entity there
are plenty of things which you can do in
salesforce this makes a very
bright wide scope for us and makes our
career safe
the reason another important point the
reason why salesforce is in high demand
is because it's highly dynamic what is
the meaning of that
see
whatever new concept comes into the
market for example
internet of things
wearable device
google glass
customized website
in all these technologies salesforce is
giving the service it means whatever new
comes into the market salesforce starts
capturing that concept
and start giving the support for the
technology so this way ultimately
because of this dynamic nature of sales
force the opportunities to adapt new
concepts in the market is very much high
bright so if something new coming into
the market
automatically sales force will give you
some kind of special facility by which
you can combine sales force as well as
the new concept
for example
you know now there is a very important
upcoming concept
internet of things
please note we know how much bright will
be the market for internet of things uh
scenarios or concept
salesforce already started working on
that so
if you have the knowledge of salesforce
then you can very well perform well
in the area of internet of thing this is
just a single example another example
you might have heard
the
you can say the gadget or let's say the
tool or device google glasses
even there are plenty of things plenty
of ways by which you can use the skill
of salesforce on their google glasses
this is a very good example to
understand how sales force is dynamic
something new coming into the market
salesforce giving the opportunity into
that as well
and the final point
market leader prediction please note
many big agencies
made survey
understood the market
understood the competition of salesforce
crm
and other segments and they predicted
that salesforce will rule the market for
minimum next 10 years because the way
sales salesforce is making growth it is
absolutely fantastic
and so guys this shows very clearly that
how salesforce is a safe career option
for of for
all of us
and this way we will not have an impact
of this roller coaster market which will
make some kind of
which will bring some kind of bad news
or some kind of fluctuation in terms of
growth every year every year or let's
say every month as compared to the
global situation
and this way
we are done with our
our webinar
and also
all those important points which will
help you to decide about your career
path now it's your turn guys please
proceed with all those valuable
questions that you have i will answer
one by one each and every question so
that we can help you
to understand this market and we can
help you to we can help you to decide
your career option and also take the
benefit of your current skill that you
have in any technology
so let's start and please keep asking
question one by one i will be happy to
answer each and every question
thank you shikhar that was a wonderful
presentation
if you don't mind can i interrupt and
we'll go ahead and do a poll well people
are coming up with some great questions
to ask
i'll go ahead and set that up on here
just a quick simple poll
and uh while i'm doing that if you have
a good question go ahead and put that
into the question section first
and then we can go and cover those here
for the last 15 minutes the poll lasts
for just a couple minutes
sure
now i did notice that um
martin earlier while we're doing the
poll he was asking about apex
uh
maybe you can expand a little bit about
what apex is used for and what kind of
connections the programming language
goes into
yeah sure
okay so so guys there is a question and
the question is related to apex the
programming language that we use in
salesforce
so martin that's a good question and now
please note yes the apex is the
programming language that we use in
salesforce
it's also called as
sister programming language of core java
it means so many things are similar in
apex
and in core java so apex is the
programming language which we use in
salesforce i hope you got the answer
martin
so other people
please come up with some kind of
questions which can help you for
deciding your roadmap
so any questions guys about your career
or
about your plans in salesforce or any
kind of thing
now we have one more very good question
let me read that for everyone
and remaining people uh please you can
type your question this is a very good
opportunity for you to get the
understanding about this tool and also
get the quick answers of all those
questions which can help you
so let me take one by one all the
questions
so many questions are coming okay first
question
now here is a question about the
job like how do you get a job without
experience after training okay now
please note that
here if you compare the concept of
having experience and non-experienced
candidate in a general
market
definitely there will be less
possibilities for people those people
who are having no experience if you take
a general technology let's say java.net
php something like this
but when there is a huge demand in the
market for any technology then these
companies will not mind hiring fresher
people
train them for a few weeks and then ask
them to handle the project
when you are already certified in
salesforce
which shows that you are already having
some kind of knowledge in terms of
business perspective
second
once you complete the course let's say
from simply learn you will get the
experience of minimum two to three
real-time project environments because
that is our agenda to give you the idea
how a project is implemented in
salesforce this all project will be also
giving you certification of experience
and then with all this background which
you have it helps you and gives you easy
platform to get a job in the market
because there is huge demand of
salesforce people no matter your new or
experience if you have certification
then the demand is very much high
i hope you you got the answer uh kevin
so now i'm going for next question so
remaining people uh please come up come
ahead with your questions as well so
that i can answer one by one and please
take the opportunity of this
i take the benefit of this opportunity
so i can help you accordingly next
question
let me read the question
okay so there is a question
which says that having a certification
in lean sigma early in six sigma
is that relevant in salesforce admin
business analyst career okay
please note that
the
importance of
six sigma certified person is definitely
very much high in the market because
that person knows how to give the best
in the project
they are working in
please note if you are a six sigma
certified and you are going to work as a
business analyst
then you will get more advantage as
compared to salesforce admin because
ultimately salesforce admin will be a
technical person
who will be performing the activities
without doing any programming
but if you are looking for a business
analyst career then
definitely you will have good
opportunity and good demand if you are a
six sigma certified person so uh
fidelis i hope you got the answer of
your question and again that was a
useful question for other people as well
so next question please guys any
questions
any question about your
plans or if you want to compare
salesforce with your current technology
for example you want to know that the
current technology in which you are
working how you can
get the easy transition from this
technology to salesforce that kind of
questions you can ask or simply you can
ask if you are looking for job
then what kind of opportunities you can
see
with your current technology please
proceed
now there is a question
okay now there is a
there is a question which will
definitely help all the candidates it's
a good question let me read the question
first
see the question is
if the job market is so competitive
what kinds of questions
or vetting
should i expect in a job interview
how can i prepare
to interview well
beyond having a certification in
salesforce okay
first of all let me make you very clear
that
if you are not certified in salesforce
then you will not get that advantage
the way
certified people will have okay that is
my advice to you so it's always good to
have certification in salesforce to get
maximum calls and maximum opportunities
now coming to the first part of your
question
how
or what kind of scenarios we are going
to face in interview now see
whenever you are going to face any
interview
in this market
first of all they would like to
understand that what kind of activities
you have done
in your previous project
they will ask you only the scenario
based question
your roles your responsibilities and
they will understand how you can be
useful for them if they hire you
this will cover 30 to 40 percent
questions in the interview
what about 60 to 70 questions
now there they will focus on your
knowledge on various technicalities
let's say for example if you are giving
the interview for salesforce admin then
they will ask you those questions
related to salesforce admin which will
test your knowledge
and which will test you how will you
implement a project with the knowledge
of admin concept
if you're a developer they will test you
how your knowledge of salesforce
programming can help them and you can
deliver well with your programming
knowledge so it's a sixty percent and
forty percent ratio forty percent
responsibilities scenarios business
aspect sixty percent will be the
technical side and your knowledge in
terms of this admin developer or
business analyst role whatever is your
current entry format okay
so i hope you got the answer of this
question and now we have one more
question
now here
one question is there from sarat and
this will help all those people who are
right now working as admins in their
current job
the question is i am working on vmware
admin is it good to switch salesforce
admin okay
please note that the difference between
vmware admin and salesforce admin is
very fine
because ultimately you are going to
control
one
application
with the skills of configurations that
is in simple word without doing
programming you are going to control the
application enhance and regularly give
some kind of service
please note if you are coming from
vmware admin into the salesforce admin
with minimum efforts you can transform
your career because you already spent
your so many months or years
understanding what are the roles and
responsibilities of a admin
then by giving slight efforts to
understand what are the roles of and
responsibilities of salesforce admin
what kind of tools they can use and
ultimately how you can
take the benefit of your existing
knowledge i think within a few weeks of
preparation you can very well perform in
the interviews of salesforce admin
and i think there is definitely
good
chance for you because of your already
existing knowledge of an admin domain i
hope sarat you got the answer of your
question
now there is one more question by uh
fidelis let me
read that it's again a detailed question
um the question is how is the salesforce
certification exam being conducted okay
good question and
it's com what is the duration of the
training okay
is there past questions and answers for
the various aspects of salesforce
certification
is there past questions and answer for
the various aspect of sales for
certification okay so fidelis if i'm not
wrong then you're asking that do we
provide
some
sample questions which came in previous
exams of certification is that correct
this is your question is that correct
fidelis
okay thank you for the information i got
all the clarity of your questions now
let me answer one by one
now
please note
first of all your first question how is
the salesforce certification exam being
conducted there are two ways
one
online mode that is you can give the
exam from your office from your home
second on-site mode that is in every
country in every major city
we have
exam center for salesforce you can book
a day and time
go there on that time and give the exam
second question what is the duration of
training please note the duration is 40
hours 4-0 40 hours
next question
is there past questions and answer yes
definitely because here
in
our agenda
of salesforce training at simply learn
we focus on giving the experience and
exposure to the two candidates
of all those previous
exam questions which came recently as
well as which may come in your exam so
ultimately you will get double benefit
you will understand what kind of
questions will be there and second what
kind of questions may come in your
examination so double benefit you will
get in this process
i hope fidelis
i have you got
answer of all your three questions
great so guys uh we have
four minutes left okay welcome fatalist
so guys we have just four minutes left
if you have any kind of questions then
you can please ask
i will be very happy to answer and help
you to get the clarity in this aspect
so
this is the question related to the
transition coming from non sales for
background to salesforce background see
the question
with companies moving to salesforce from
other platforms
would i need to underst would i need an
understanding of sap oracle or microsoft
to help a company make their move to
salesforce
would i have a competitive advantage in
the job market if i did okay first of
all if you don't know even the
background
how these technologies or the brands
working in their domain it's absolutely
fine no problem because here our focus
will be understanding the current
business of customer not the current
tool
so
for example if my current customer who
is working on microsoft they want to
convert in salesforce we don't need to
worry about microsoft tool we only need
to understand how they are working in
microsoft tools the business aspect
then we need to convert all these
business requirements into the
salesforce functionalities with some
specific steps
and that's it you have a roadmap ready
you can start working on the project so
no need to have the idea about these
other tools
there is one more question would i have
a competitive advantage in the job
market if i did yes definitely if you
have the knowledge of multiple platforms
you will have a good advantage in the
market but please note
it is not compulsory okay so i hope you
got the answer of this question
yes richard so we are done with the
thing i think all the questions are done
from student side
thank you everybody for showing up thank
you jeff kevin sarath shinee uh we
greatly appreciate you coming here we'll
go ahead and close down the
presentation for today and hope you guys
happy learning have a great day
you